hey what is up everybody its Anna Mack
here for anime uproar and today I will
be talking about the latest absolutely
historic events in the boku no hero
story this is it
this is the watershed moment that
absolutely changes the story things will
never be the same again from now on this
series is going to have a distinctly
darker tone and shigaraki in particular
has just become a completely different
person he has just been referred to as a
transcendent super human being a plus
ultra villain and already the casualties
are mounting including top tier pro
heroes seriously this is a historic
moment in the boku no hero story so
let's get into it
if you enjoyed the boku no hero content
on the channel and you want to see more
please leave a like to let me know it
really does help and if you happen to be
new to anime uproar or you just haven't
subscribed yet please consider
subscribing and hitting that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of clicking that
bell and then selecting the option that
says all if you don't do that you're
still gonna miss a lot of our videos
even if you're subscribed
it's just how YouTube works you can also
hit me up on Twitter and Instagram at
anime uproar finally this video will of
course contain boku no hero manga
spoilers we're talking about the very
latest groundbreaking events in the
story so with that in mind please
proceed with caution you have been
warned
back in Chapter 270 we saw that
shigaraki
was indeed awakening but in Chapter 272
the very first panel confirms that she
got Aki's eyes are open immediately
after that first panel the chapter
quickly shifts to the area around the
hospital where the heroes and hero
students are evacuating civilians just
in case the battle against the villains
at jakku hospital ends up spilling over
to the rest of the city and boy that
sure was the right call because things
would get absolutely crazy really
quickly as we found out later in this
after burnin is coordinating the
evacuation efforts and the hero students
including our friends from class 1a are
doing their best to evacuate everyone to
give extra help to those who may need it
and so on most of the characters that we
see here are well known to us like the
class 1a students and nej'ta although
there are one or two heroes that I
didn't recognize one really cool touch
that I saw in this scene was the fact
that the heroes were even able to
evacuate everyone's pets and the other
animals in the area thanks to Coda's
quirk and a voice finally our boy Koda
is actually being useful no offense to
him but his quirk definitely isn't
suited for every situation it is very
specific everything seems to be going
well
until that moment from the end of
chapter 270 the moment in which Deku
stops in his tracks
his expression changes completely and he
says the words he's coming at first the
other students have no idea what Dec was
talking about but Deku is hearing a
voice inside his head that is telling
him that he has to stop Shigure Aki the
voice appears to be coming from one for
all itself and dec who interprets it as
being the voice of the very first one
for all user the brother of all for one
and man it sure is crazy how much the
original one for all user looks like she
got a key we've talked about this before
pretty much everyone has talked about it
by now but come on this can't be just a
coincidence according to the voice
inside the coos head an unbelievable
power has just been freed from its human
shackles shigaraki has become a
transcendent being a super human being
and he is coming the awakened shigaraki
just underwent a procedure that allowed
him to surpass his former limitations
and to inherit all for one on top of his
already Opie awakened quark decay and
speaking of shigaraki on the very next
page we see that he is sitting up poor X
less turned suddenly and shigaraki just
casually says that he is cold
in the next moment the whole world
changes as present Mike is carrying huge
eco and as the heroes are fighting the
various different nomu everyone suddenly
realizes that the entire building is
beginning to disintegrate and this
disintegration is coming from the very
place that shigaraki had been located
everyone runs for their lives Gran
Torino grabs you Chico and present Mike
and they blast off just as the entire
lab disintegrates and everything is
destroyed including all those canisters
containing copies of quirks that Luca
was using in order to create the Nommo
and give them powers gran torino quickly
realizes that she gerak his quark decay
is what's destroying the building but
unlike before when he needed to touch
something directly in order to decay it
the decay is now spreading like crazy to
everything in the building Gran Torino
urges all the heroes to get out of there
right now and to be careful not to touch
any surface that is already decaying so
all the heroes make a run for it but one
of the Nommo manages to grab aizawa's
leg
the shield hero crust uses one of his
shields to cut the normals arm and save
Aizawa but just as he saves Aizawa crust
is completely disintegrated much - Aiza
was shocked a lot of the heroes do
manage to make it out including the UQ
Aizawa present Mike Gran Torino and
thankfully endeavour grabs my girl
miracle and manages to bring her outside
as well I am of course extremely
relieved that miracle appears to have
been saved miracle is life but I do feel
kind of bad for crust in my previous
videos I kept saying that as long as
medic was safe I would totally be okay
if some other heroes like crusts had to
go and now that is exactly what happened
ex less and crusts are gone
killed by shigaraki ex less probably
didn't even see it coming
and to his eternal credit crust went out
like a true hero he saved the fellow
hero and was brave and heroic until the
very end
but make no mistake other heroes have
also been killed during this
both inside the hospital and outside as
the decay continues to spread although
to be honest we still have no idea of
what the full death toll is going to
look like when all of this is over
however we do see that the laundry hero
Washu is in the direct vicinity of the
decay and then we see other heroes being
disintegrated in that same area so it
appears that Washu may also have been
killed bro during these tough times
Washu is exactly the type of hygienic
hero that we need it would honestly
really suck if we lost such a me mobile
character before we even saw his full
potential in action as the decay spreads
beyond the hospital and into the streets
pixie Bob of the wild wild Pussycats
uses her quirk earth flow to throw a
bunch of earth at the decay in order to
stop it from spreading and this does
appear to be somewhat effective from
what I can tell although I have to say
right now that this chapter does not
confirm whether pixie bob was able to
actually stop the decay or whether she
was killed in the process
the chapter just keeps shifting from one
place to another so quickly that we
don't get to see what happens to all the
heroes caught up in the carnage but I
think there is some hope that pixie Bob
and the other Pussycats survived
we know that chick Iraqis quark is not
very effective on small morsels like
sand so maybe this earth that pixie Bob
threw up at the decay really was able to
stop the destruction in this area or
maybe she was able to split the earth in
a way that stopped the decay from
spreading further
I certainly hope that pixie Bob survived
she is yet another brave and beautiful
pro-hero waifu in the boku no hero story
but so much is happening in this chapter
so quickly and we just don't know the
full extent of the damage that shigaraki
has managed to cause for his part ug co
is amazed by what is happening he
believes that this is the moment they've
all been waiting for the victory for the
villains
and of course he is amazed that she
gerak he was able to withstand so much
suffering and awaken against all odds
she gerak he has become a new superhuman
villain a villain whose
physical limitations have been removed a
plus ultra shigaraki it is truly ironic
how the heroes and hero students are
always talking about going beyond going
plus ultra and all might and deku
especially are all about surpassing your
limits in the name of being a hero doing
the impossible in order to help others
and embodying the plus ultra life and
yet she Guara key has now become the
plus ultra villain shigaraki has become
the anti Deku the shown and protagonist
but for the villains he is the hero of
my villain academia and this is
something that horikoshi has been
establishing for a while she got a key
and all for one really are the evil
counterparts to Deku and all might in so
many ways for much of the series Deku
has been surpassing his limits and
tapping into one for all's overpowered
abilities in just the right moment this
has been happening so long that I was
honestly worried that that code would
become too strong too quickly I mean he
is still only in the first year of high
school and if dec who does become too
overpowered and too broken who could
possibly challenge him well what I
didn't anticipate is that shigaraki
would also gain overpowered protagonist
powers except he is going to use them
for evil shigaraki as he is right now is
more than a challenge for Deku even at
his most broken and overpowered and that
I have to say is truly impressive on the
part of horikoshi and the story is about
to get even more crazy from here so as
half of the frickin city crumbles
Fujiko rejoices because everything that
the heroes have been building up to this
point will now be destroyed with a
single touch when he says this Fujiko
isn't just referring to the buildings
that are being destroyed he is referring
to the hero society as a whole
including the concept of pro heroes
itself and of course he is talking about
the sense of security that the general
population has enjoyed for all of these
years as a result of the pro hero system
this is truly a paradigm shift
the events of this chapter won't just
shift the balance of power between the
villains and heroes they will also shift
the very mentality of the people who
live within the hero society the people
will now learn that the heroes cannot
protect them not anymore
and panic and chaos will surely ensue
realizing what's happening Dec who
rushes into the thick of it and prepares
a 45 percent San Luis smash air force as
he does this he tells everyone else to
get away and that is how this
unbelievable unprecedented and historic
chapter ends deku is going all-out 45
percent is no joke
and I believe that he is trying to blow
the decay back or cut it off in his
tracks by creating a sharp blast of
compressed air but can he really stop
the decay for long can he possibly stop
the decay from spreading in all the
different directions that it is
currently spreading in for maybe the
first time in the story I think that
even Dec who may not be able to get the
heroes out of this one and that is
saying a lot oh and now might be a good
time to mention that shigaraki appears
to have done all of this ie destroyed
half the freaking city with just a
single touch of one of his hands this is
an insane level of power it is
completely game-changing and things will
never be the same again as I said
earlier at the end of this chapter we
are not sure what exactly happened to
all of the characters including notably
the high and normal we can assume that
the nomu that tried to grab Aizawa was
destroyed but what about the other ones
including the female nomu we could
assume that they were all destroyed
along with everything else in the
hospital but I'm not going to believe
that unless we actually see it happen
with our own eyes these high-end gnome
will have insane regeneration quirks so
I wouldn't be surprised if some of them
made it out in the case of the female
nomu in particular I think that there is
still more to her story so I am NOT
writing her off just yet all in all we
knew that this was coming we knew that
it was about to happen and yet seeing it
happen like this is still absolutely
unreal
my main takeaway
from this hour oh man am I glad that
miracle was saved by endeavor and oh man
shiitake is an absolute monster multiple
heroes are dead including some top tier
heroes crust was the number six pro hero
and he is gone wash is the number eight
pro hero and he might also be gone and
who knows how many lesser-known heroes
also perished within the span of just a
few minutes there is no going back from
this Deku and the other pro heroes will
not be able to just move on the wider
hero society will also not be able to
move on from this disaster what we just
witnessed was a hero massacre and it's
probably only the beginning Deku Aizawa
and everyone else will never be the same
again from a psychological perspective
and this series just became a whole lot
darker I think it's safe to say that
this is shaping up to be the best and
most impactful arc in the entire series
the balance of power has shifted and the
psychology of the heroes and the hero
students is bound to also shift not to
mention the psychology of the general
population as a whole
forget the symbol of peace because there
is no more peace forget any sense of
security because no one is safe anymore
up until this point in the story
horikoshi had created a fascinating hero
society and now he has turned it on its
head he has just destroyed the hero
society as we knew it and something new
and completely different will have to be
created in its place
and I honestly can't wait to see what
happens next because now the
possibilities are endless there is no
more neutral gear there is no more
status quo everything we thought we knew
about this hero world just disintegrated
before our eyes all I have to say is
whoa and Wow
please let me know you guys think are
you as shocked and amazed as I am after
the events of this chapter who do you
think actually survived
Shikha Rocky's decay and who do you
think lost their lives also does that
goo stand any chance whatsoever in
defeating shigaraki
and if so what can he possibly do oh and
I just realized that I didn't even talk
about began to makea who is also about
to let loose on the heroes back at the
villain mansion man the story of boku no
hero has never been so intense
and I absolutely love it although at the
same time I am a bit scared about which
characters we might lose next if you
enjoyed this video and you want us to
keep it go and please leave a like to
let me know and if you happen to be new
to anime uproar or you just haven't
subscribed yet please consider
subscribing and hitting that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications feel free to hit me up on
Twitter and Instagram ads anime uproar I
want to give a big thank you to all of
our anime opera patrons who make videos
like this one possible a very special
thank you to a friend a a disciple of
Lord Twigg o himself and I can't forget
our the one tier patrons the ones who
rise above all other clans including
Ingrid ah Allen Adham of the world
steelers tyson qui dino acquired respect
pat a heffa Jonathan king deci d Brandon
Aviles Papa Smurf Emperor otaku and
Ritchie Martinez finally thank you also
to all our pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only Gilgamesh
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson King
zelgius Anatole Cassatt's key on hell
Cruz hi Sparky 65 cricket XP Ted no Ted
Joe Stanton very Gucci Alicia ahktar on
Imola 69 jessica calif on dino combien
water bonnie parks saudi art 12 rothwyn
day ora emperor mitch loves anime
cynical Kraken and JCCC waka
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value for you please
consider supporting us on patreon even a
single dollar will give you access to
our patron exclusive discord and your
name will appear in our videos along
with these legendary people as always
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time see us space cowboys
[Music]